Antoine goyatte a attaqué dans plusieurs
vidéos une réaction à ses attaques ben
Antoine Goya je trouve ça un petit peu
triste ce qui lui arrive je trouve ça un
petit peu désolant pour tout vous dire
parce qu'il a complètement abandonné le
terrain des idées il a complètement
abandonné le fond et maintenant il se
concentre uniquement sur la forme c'est
à dire clasher pour clasher contredire
pour contredire avec des techniques qui
sont toujours les mêmes c'est à dire la
mauvaise foi la déformation les insultes
en fait on est passé de quelqu’un qui
mettait le clash au service de la
culture et qui maintenant très
clairement mais la culture au service du
clash et là ces dernières semaines on a
assisté à l'explosion en plein vol
d'Antoine Goya c'est-à-dire non
seulement un festival de mauvaise foi et
de malhonnêteté mais maintenant on a
quelque chose de plus qui est carrément
la schizophrénie c'est à dire qu'Antoine
Goya arrive à se contredire non
seulement d'une vidéo à l'autre mais
même une phrase à l'autre donc pour ceux
qui n'ont pas suivi l'affaire j'ai fait
une vidéo FAQ il y a quelques mois dans
laquelle j'ai montré qu'Antoine Goya
avait déformé la pensée de Tolstoï pour
la faire coller à ce qu'il voulait dire
à propos de l'art contemporain parce que
bon je suis désolé mais si t'étais
Tolstoï pour défendre l'art contemporain
c'est comme si tu es Hitler pour
défendre le vivre ensemble ça va aucun
sens donc Antoine Goya n'a pas apprécié
que je mette en lumière sa manipulation
il n'a pas apprécié que je mette le
doigt sur sa mauvaise foi et donc pour
tenter de se justifier il a fait trois
vidéos d'affilée sur moi alors on va
être bien clair quand on fait trois
vidéos d'affilée sur quelqu'un c'est
qu'il a touché quelque chose et surtout
ça veut dire que les deux premières
vidéos n'ont pas suffi donc petit
conseil aux youtubeurs qui se lancerait
si vous voulez répondre à quelqu'un
faites-le en une seule fois et passez à
autre chose parce que sinon vous risquez
de tomber dans l'obsession surtout quand
vous faites trois vidéos pour parler de
tout sauf du bouger c'est à dire que
dans ces trois vidéos de réponses
Antoine Goya a soigneusement esquivé la
question Tolstoï en fait ça c'est
quelque chose que j'ai remarqué chez lui
c'est que quand il est pris en défaut
sur un sujet sa technique c'est de
parler d'autre chose le problème avec
cette stratégie c'est que vous avez
beaucoup croire que les gens ne vont pas
s'en rendre compte si ça se voit ça se
remarque faire diversion c'est un des
stratagèmes les plus visibles et les
plus grossiers en rhétorique alors il a
quand même essayé de me répondre sur
Tolstoï mais ça je vais le garder pour
la fin parce que vous allez voir que
s'accroustille et donc au lieu de me
répondre sur le fond café Antoine Goya
bah il a fait ce qu'on fait généralement
quand on est pris en flagrant délit de
mauvaise foi c'est-à-dire de
l'agressivité des mensonges des attaques
personnelles des attaques sur ma diction
des attaques sur mon style vestimentaire
et ça la limite je m'en fiche parce que
c'est la logique du spectacle et que
quand quelqu'un vous insulte sur
Internet faut pas le prendre
personnellement mais qui est vraiment
amusant c'est qu'Antoine Goya et
ressenti le besoin de recourir à des
attaques personnelles alors que dans le
même temps il est le premier à dire que
quand on utilise des attaques
personnelles c'est la preuve qu'on a
rien à répondre sur le fond donc moi ce
que j'aimerais savoir c'est comment on
fait pour d'un côté dire que les
attaques personnelles c'est le niveau
zéro de l'argumentation et d'un autre
côté utilisez des attaques personnelles
pour répondre à quelqu'un à moins d'être
schizophrène le mec il est tellement
vulgaire que tu as plutôt l'impression
qu'il va te proposer une fille pour pas
cher plutôt que de parler de philosophie
alors là clairement tu doutes bien que
les attaques sur le physique que les
menaces bah ça vole pas très haut que
c'est tout en bas et donc pour l'instant
tu n'as toujours pas invalidé mon propos
parce que du coup Charles Robin donc là
il a son costume de maquereau il va
faire des vidéos avec potier civilisé là
dans les rues de Nice où il est de la
terre comme ça sur le beau avec le torse
ouvert faut savoir que les attaques
personnages c'est clairement l'argument
le plus faible dans ce tout le reste a
échoué et en plus le mec il parle
tellement lentement tu as envie de le
mettre de secouer toi il est en train de
faire un AVC en fait le seul truc que tu
fais en faisant des abdominales c'est
d'essayer de mettre de ton côté parce
que si tu te mets à t'en prendre à la
personne et bien les gens vont venir
ricaner avec toi effectivement tu es en
train de raconter quoi de là le
précepteur c'est bien tu as pas suivi la
vidéo ou quoi viens te montrer qu'en
fait c'est un tocard qui racontait
n'importe quoi lorsqu'on se rend compte
que l'adversaire nous est supérieur et
nous autres tout raison il faut alors
devenir personnel insultant mal poli
donc c'est pas la peine de faire le gros
cerveau en train de dire oui en fait
c'est seulement lorsque ça va dans leur
sens et tout c'est bon ta gueule
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il t'enlève tous
les sophisme toutes les attaques à
personne il n'y a plus rien d'accord
dans son discours bon c'est un peu
l'hôpital qui se fout de la charité bon
alors il y a les insultes mais il y a
surtout tout le film qu'Antoine Goya
s'est construit dans la tête parce que
figurez-vous qu'Antoine Goya est
persuadé que si je les critiquais sur
Tolstoï c'est parce que j'aurais été
vexé par l'un de ses tweets dans lequel
il disait du mal de ma bande dessinée ce
qui veut dire quand même que pour
Antoine Goya quand on critique quelqu'un
ça ne peut pas être pour des raisons de
fond
c'est forcément qu'on a été vexé c'est
forcément qu'on a été blessé dans son
ego ça peut pas être parce que vous avez
déformé la pensée d'un auteur pour
pouvoir l'utiliser comme un argument
d'autorité donc si on suit la logique
d'Antoine Goya s'il a fait trois vidéos
sur moi c'est parce qu'il a été très
très vexé en même temps quand on dit à
quelqu'un je ne te raterai pas
effectivement ça sent un peu le
ressentiment donc j'aurais été vexé par
le tweet d'Antoine Goya sur ma BD ok le
problème c'est que le tweet dont parle
Antoine Goya date du 15 octobre alors
que ma FAQ je l'ai enregistré le 9 août
le 9 août c'est à dire deux mois avant
Charles Robin a fait une grossière
erreur il a été vexé vexé car j'ai
utilisé mes gros doigts pour faire des
tweets des tweets sur sa future bande
dessinée galère fort nul donc voilà bon
il a été vexé donc il a attaqué mes
vidéos sur l'art sans doute pour
défendre ses copines de droit tarder
[Musique]
que penses-tu des vidéos d'Antoine Goya
qui sont axés sur la philosophie et le
cinéma en général
[Musique]
et donc la solution pour discuter si tu
as quelqu'un qui commet des sophisme
face à toi c'est pas de l'insulter la
solution est très simple c'est de
montrer ses sophisme
on va continuer un peu parce que c'est
intéressant donc Antoine Goya n'ayant
fait la promesse de ne pas me rater bah
il s'est demandé sur quoi il allait
pouvoir m'attaquer et donc il a choisi
de critiquer ma vidéo avec barbare
civilisé sur l'art et la beauté et donc
pour pouvoir m'attaquer qu'est-ce qu'il
a fait et ben il m'a carrément inventé
des propos c'est à dire que là encore il
s'est construit un film dans sa tête ça
doit être son côté cinéphile
c'est-à-dire que comme il combat l'idée
que le but de l'art ça devrait être la
beauté mais ce qu'il fait c'est qu'il
m'attribue cette position pour pouvoir
ensuite m'attaquer là dessus mais le
problème c'est que c'est pas du tout ça
ma position sur l'art tout simplement
parce que pour moi l'art n'a pas qu'un
seul but donc on est en plein délire et
le pire dans tout ça et c'est là où
vraiment je pense qu'il prend ses
spectateurs pour des idiots c'est que
pour illustrer ça
il utilise un extrait dans lequel je ne
parle même pas de la beauté mais dans
lequel je parle de la fonction
d'édification en art donc oui vous avez
bien entendu pour me faire dire que
l'art était lié à la beauté il a montré
un extrait dans lequel je ne parlais pas
de la beauté parce que du coup Charles
Robin donc là il a son costume de Macron
il va faire des vidéos avec potier
civilisé là dans les rues de Nice où il
est de la terre comme ça sur le beau
avec le torse ouvert il y a comme ça on
peut dire oh le beau regard de le beau
bref des conneries habituelles de droit
tarder
si tu regardes dans l'Antiquité les
statues antiques c'était des hymnes à la
force c'était des Inno courage à la
vertu pourquoi parce que la guerre
faisait partie du quotidien et donc les
oeuvres d'art avaient aussi une fonction
d'édification c'est-à-dire qu'on devait
susciter chez les citoyens le goût de la
vertu le goût du courage le goût de
l'héroïsme
il y a comme ça on peut dire eux le beau
regard de le beau bref des conneries
habituelles de droit tarder si tu
commences par falsifier les propos des
gens ça va pas aller
en fait Antoine Goya adore avoir des
adversaires il aime avoir des
adversaires parce que toute son image
repose sur le clash c'est à dire que si
vous lui enlevez le clash Antoine Goya
n'existe plus sur Youtube c'est pour ça
qu'il admettra jamais sa mauvaise foi
sur Tolstoï c'est pour ça qu'à chaque
fois qu'il s'en prend à quelqu'un sur
youtube il ne dit que des choses
négatives il y a jamais de nuance et à
jamais de volonté de comprendre pourquoi
l'autre pense ce qu'il pense parce que
ce serait mauvais pour son image de
clasheur et parce que ses abonnés ne
seraient pas contents en fait son besoin
d'avoir des adversaires le pouce en
fabriquer et qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
pour fabriquer un adversaire bah faut
fabriquer des propos avec lesquels on
n'est pas d'accord il faut faire dire à
l'autre des choses avec lesquelles on
n'est pas d'accord quitte à les inventer
quitte à les fantasmer pour pouvoir
ensuite l'attaquer là dessus donc quand
dans la vidéo vidéo je parle du réalisme
art que fait Antoine Goya il coupe
lorsque le réalisme a commencé à se
développer en opposition au romantisme
d'ailleurs c'est à dire en opposition à
l'exaltation à l'idéal et à la
transcendance beaucoup de critiques
d'art à l'époque se sont insurgés en
disant que on pouvait pas appeler ça de
l'art parce que il y avait aucune notion
de surpassement il y avait aucune notion
d'exaltation et ni même de beauté quand
je parle de l'émotion en art il coupe
tout l'enjeu au cinéma c'est de de faire
ressentir ses émotions comme si elles
étaient réelles pour que ce ne soit plus
une scène qu'on regarde mais qu'on
assiste au spectacle de l'émotion qui se
déploie en nous quand je parle de
l'évolution du rapport sujet objet en
art la distinction entre le spectateur
et le regardeur il coupe le regardeur
par distinction du spectateur le
spectateur c'est celui qui assiste à un
spectacle donc le spectateur il a
quelque chose devant lui quelque chose
qui est posé devant sa conscience il va
entrer en interaction avec l'oeuvre
alors que le regardeur c'est presque
celui qui va
poser sa signification sur les choses
donc ça veut dire que la signification
n'est plus dans l'oeuvre elle est dans
l'oeil du spectateur qui regarde
l'oeuvre il coupe parce que sinon il
serait obligé de reconnaître que non
seulement je ne tiens pas les propos
qu'il me prêtent mais qu'en plus il y a
des choses avec lesquelles il serait
d'accord mais ça ce serait la fin pour
lui Antoine Goya qui concept des points
son adversaire en fait Antoine Goya ne
veut pas que vous entendiez ce que ces
adversaires disent il veut que vous
entendiez ça reformulation de ce qu'ils
disent parce que toutes ces attaques
reposent sur la déformation des propos
qui critiquent et c'est là qu'on en
arrive à ces attaques sur ma bande
dessinée alors si on va bande dessinée
c'est magnifique parce qu'après nous
avoir expliqué sur tous les tons que la
beauté en art on s'en foutait
il reproche à ma bande dessinée d'être
moche mais c'est juste moche c'est
dégueulasse c'est ça le beau pour toi
c'est ça le beau mais non mais c'est
dégueulasse c'est immonde mais là il y a
un vrai problème surtout elle se tu
racontes avec ton discours ce problème
c'est qu'on s'en bat les couilles de
savoir si une œuvre d'art est belle donc
la beauté n'est pas un critère en art
sauf pour Charles Robin ah oui alors
visiblement Antoine Goya ne connaît pas
la différence entre une bande dessinée
et un manuel scolaire je suis désolé
mais lorsqu'on fait un cours pour ceux
qui ont déjà ouvert un manuel dans un
manuel en fait il y a une page de manuel
c'était pensé c'est à dire qu'il y a des
designers qui sont amusés à dire ok là
on va mettre les définitions là on va
mettre le coup on va mettre des mots en
gras on va mettre des éléments on va
mettre un texte de référence et tout
pour articuler tout ça alors on va quand
même prendre le temps de lui expliquer
parce que c'est important donc tu vois
sans Antoine ça c'est un manuel scolaire
carnet de réussite des éditions Hatier
auxquels j'ai collaboré d'ailleurs tu
vois ça c'est mon petit logo et tu vois
à l'intérieur de ce manuel bah là on a
effectivement des définitions
on a des mots clés on a des cartes
mentales et puis là tu vois on a une
bande dessinée alors tu vois ça se
présente sous une autre forme c'est plus
grand déjà et puis bah à l'intérieur
qu'est-ce qu'on a ben on a des on a des
dessins voilà on a des dessins on a du
texte c'est très différent donc tu vois
la bande dessinée ici et là le manuel
scolaire non mais je me moque mais c'est
pas méchant et entre nous c'est rien à
côté de l'autre critique qu'Antoine Goya
a fait de ma bande dessinée c'est à dire
qu'il m'a attaqué sur le fait que
j'avais utilisé la lettre Phi dans mon
titre comme abandonné s'appelle filorama
fille c'est le symbole de la philosophie
et en majuscule ça ressemble à un haut
un haut barré donc j'ai utilisé ce qu'on
appelle une parodie c'est à dire une
ressemblance de caractères pour intégrer
dans mon titre une référence à la
philosophie donc bref vous avez compris
j'ai utilisé fille parce que ça
ressemble à un haut voilà en fait je me
sens très mal à l'aise d'expliquer ça à
quelqu'un qui cite Tolstoï et Nietzsche
je sais pas si vous en rendez compte
mais Antoine Goya est convaincu que si
j'ai mis la lettre fi dans mon titre
c'est parce que je ne sais pas comment
se prononce la lettre Phi donc si on
suit la logique d'Antoine Goya il
faudrait pas dire Dragon Ball Z non il
faudrait dire
drag boules de cristal handball Z si on
suit la logique d'Antoine il faudrait
pas dire Alcatel il faudrait dire halte
triangle il faudrait pas dire Zippo
faudrait dire zette flamme peau non mais
je veux bien qu'il faille faire du
spectacle mais là c'est gênant le
précepteur voilà le petit Charles Robin
dans toute sa vulgarité sa médiocrité
qu'est-ce qu'il a mis au milieu du nom
de sa BD donc la philo Rama il a mis un
fi ok tu as mis un fille au milieu du
nom de ta BD à la place du haut
deuxièmement le fils et le fils de
philosophie donc en fait là il y a
marqué un truc genre philo Frama ou je
sais pas quoi bon ok on fait fi comme ça
vous savez
c'est bien beau de mettre la lettre
fille pour frimer encore faut-il la
mettre au bon endroit voilà donc au
début vous posez le doigt fais pas le
mec qui parle grec mec tu as mis un
fille au milieu du titre de ta BD tu
sais même pas le prononcer les lettres
grecques fais pas les lénistes puis
après vous tournez ça fait fi voilà la
lettre fi et son symbole la prochaine
fois tu penses
[Musique]
tu es comme ça tout est comme ça on
pourrait continuer pendant des heures
par exemple Antoine Goya a fait sa
deuxième vidéo sur moi pour critiquer
mon épisode sur le wokisme j'aurais
préféré qu'il parle de Tolstoï mais
admettons et donc qu'est-ce qu'il dit
dans sa vidéo il dit que ce que je dis
sur le vaucisme n'a aucun sens parce que
personne ne se revendique du walkisme et
pour illustrer ça il utilise un extrait
dans lequel je dis moi-même que personne
ne se revendique du motisme je dis
textuellement pas implicitement
textuellement que le mot moquisme n'a
pas été inventé par les woks et Antoine
Goya me répond que personne ne se
réclame du wauquisme Antoine quand tu
fais le montage de tes vidéos assure-toi
que je ne dise pas le contraire de ce
que tu me fais dire moi les auteurs Revo
que j'en connais pas qui se revendique
du walkisme alors déjà il faut savoir
que ce mot ou autisme
n'est pas une auto désignation on peut
la citer des gens dont les bouquins se
réfèrent pour baser leurs pensées ce ne
sont pas les walks qui ont inventé le
mot wauquisme d'ailleurs dans ta vidéo
on voit que tu es incapable de citer un
auteur walkiste voilà c'est basé sur
personne ce sont les opposants à la
pensée wok qui ont inventé ce mot dans
un but de dénigrement et donc là ça
c'est ce que tu fais tu parles dans le
terme intersectionnel par contre docteur
bouquet il y en a pas comment il
s'appelle l'auteur interceptionnel là
et alors attendez c'est pas fini parce
qu'Antoine Goya c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui est capable de me
reprocher d'utiliser le mot wok mais qui
dans ces vidéos se moque de ce qu'il
appelle les Who légumes alors là je suis
d'accord avec Charles complotis est un
terme qui est fourni je suis d'accord
c'est un terme qui est fourre-tout mais
peut-être Charles comme un autre terme
que tu as utilisé récemment dont j'ai
déjà parlé en vidéo peut-être comme le
terme wok est un terme fourre-tout la
qualité est indépendante du fait que le
film soit wok que légumes ou non et toi
si tu t'intéresses c'est que ça soit wok
que le légume bah oui le terme brut
c'est un terme pour tout que tu veux
discréditer un adversaire de gauche tu
vas le traiter de wok parfois
l'idéologie ou légume elle gâche le film
et ça là ça ça c'est bien ça c'est le
progrès etc ça c'est wake aux légumes et
donc pour critiquer mon épisode sur le
wokism Antoine Goya a fait appel à son
ami puisque lui-même il connaît rien bah
c'est pas il déjà c'est elle et ce qui
est vraiment ironique
c'est que si on met en parallèle ce que
dit Antoine Goya dans ses vidéos et ce
que dit son ami sur le wokisme dans
s’aperçoit qu'Antoine Goya dit
exactement l'inverse autrement dit comme
avec Tolstoï Antoine Goya se cache
derrière une autorité avec laquelle il
ne lui même pas d'accord elle nous fait
le fameux niveau 0 un peu
de la pensée dite wok c'est de dire que
les mots parle de race donc ils sont
racistes là clairement c'est du racisme
c'est-à-dire que oui le mal blanc comme
ça il est on précise bien sa couleur en
précisant 7 donc ça c'est du racisme et
du sexisme la femme noire a une
discrimination qui est particulière en
tant que femme noire en fait j'ai
vraiment l'impression que les femmes
elles se rendent pas compte que ce que
eux elles croient et des oppressions
systémiques blablabla mon cul en fait
tout le monde les vit tout le temps du
coup ce que font les militants de gauche
c'est qu'ils essaient de comprendre ce
qu'est une race pour pouvoir lutter
contre le racisme
son seul truc ton seul problème c'est
qu'on dit que tu manges des nems ça va
je pense que il y a pire dans la vie
quand on parle de féminisme en fait on
parle de la femme blanche bourgeoise et
puis quand on parle de racisme on parle
plutôt de la discrimination envers les
hommes noirs c'est quoi ton problème
enfin clairement je veux dire tu vis
dans un pays où il y a une majorité
blanche
pourquoi est-ce que tu râles parce que
les standards c'est blanc 4 blanc c'est
pas juste être blanc de peau tout
bêtement c'est être reconnu comme blanc
si jamais tu veux pas vivre dans un
monde où il y a des blancs pourquoi tu
vas pas dans un monde où il y a pas de
blanc et là le fait que Charles romain
comprenne pas ça ça me pousse à dire que
les
mots j'ai même pas convaincre les domin
ants comme ils sont par exemple blanc ou
hétéros il serait mauvais en soi ça part
du principe que tous les blancs sont
racistes parce qu'ils sont nés dans une
société raciste qui est faite pour les
blancs donc tu as beau être le plus
déconstruit possible tu resteras quand
même un gros raciste fragile en fait un
wok dit qu'un blanc peut renier sa
blanchitée en quelque sorte il peut
sortir du système de domination
justement en comprenant les
discriminations raciales par exemple
genre ça c'est ça ça pue la morale des
stars on vous a fait la leçon vous étiez
méchant maintenant vous essayez d'être
bon comme nous on est bon et toute
critique formulée par une personne de
couleur envers toi sera légitime et toi
tu as juste à t'écraser c'est bien ça
qu'il faut retenir bon vous vous en
doutez si jamais je prends la peine d'en
faire une vidéo c'est que c'est très
clairement de la merde
ah oui ça c'est pas mal aussi Antoine
Goya a reproché à Modin malin de cette
appuyé pour le critiquer sur une
interview parce qu'une interview c'est
toujours un peu plus approximatif on
n'est jamais aussi précis en interview
que dans une vidéo préparée et ça je
suis absolument mais sauf que 5 minutes
avant sur quoi est-ce qu'Antoine Goya
s'est appuyé pour me critiquer sur un
entretien j'ai donné donc une interview
sur la chaîne de d'une Focus sur le
sujet de la politique et de l'art
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait tu t'amuses à
répondre à une interview cette vidéo
c'est à l'extrait d'un entretien qu'il a
mené chez absol vous savez absolument il
fait des entretiens qui doivent durer 12
heures là je sais pas quoi c'est chiant
comme la pluie je vais donner les
conditions de l'interview donc je
sortais de 8e de présentation là au club
de l'étoile où j'ai présenté mes Médicis
d'ailleurs c'était très bien pour ceux
qui étaient je pense que vous avez aussi
beaucoup kiffé et donc du coup le
dernier soir j'ai dormi trois heures
j'étais torché dans Paris sur les
Champs-Élysées bref j'ai rien compris je
savais plus où j'étais cette vidéo c'est
à l'extrait d'un entretien qu'il a mené
chez absol vous savez absolument durer
12 heures là je sais pas quoi c'est
chiant comme la pluie donc c'est une
vidéo qui a été tournée en décembre
d'alcool après 3 heures de sommeil bon
ok très bien donc toi tu choisis de
répondre à ça une interview hey toujours
être honnête toujours être honnête moi
je suis pas ancien jeune mens pas mais
je vous dis tout est comme ça le pire je
crois qu'en fait c'est que j'ai même pas
besoin de commenter en fait si vous
voulez débloquer Antoine Goya il y a pas
besoin de commenter
vous prenez ce qu'il a dit à un instant
T vous prenez ce qu'il a dit 5 minutes
après et voilà vous avez des bonnes cas
Antoine Goya ou alors vous prenez ce
qu'il vous fait dire et vous prenez ce
que vous avez vraiment dit et vous
comparez parce que comme je disais tout
à l'heure Antoine Goya ça l'intéresse
pas ce que vous dites de toute façon il
écoute pas ce que vous dites donc j'ai
pas regardé bien sûr cette entretien non
ce qui l'intéresse c'est de reformuler
vos propos c'est de les déformer c'est
de les extrapoler pour pouvoir vous
faire dire quelque chose d'attaquable
mais honnêtement Antoine est-ce que tu
pensais vraiment que ça pouvait
fonctionner est-ce que tu croyais
vraiment que les gens qui m'écoutent ou
même les gens qui t'écoutent toi
pouvaient tomber dans le panneau les
gens qui te suivent et qui vont tomber
sur cette vidéo crois-moi bien que c'est
pas à moi qui vais en vouloir c'est à
toi qu'ils vont en vouloir de les avoir
pris pour des imbéciles c'est à toi
qu'il va en vouloir d'avoir voulu les
manipuler de manière aussi grossière
juste pour satisfaire ton ego de
clasheur est-ce que vous vous voulez
encore un exemple j'en ai des tartines
par exemple Antoine Goya dit que je
cherche absolument à me faire passer
pour quelqu'un de neutre l'ennui c'est
que dans l'entretien que j'ai fait avec
absol je dis explicitement que la
neutralité n'existe pas je crois que je
dis même de mémoire la neutralité ça
n'existe pas c'est du pipeau parce qu'on
injecte toujours dans les auteurs notre
propre sensibilité et ça c'est pas
quelque chose que j'ai dit une seule
fois c'est quelque chose que j'ai répété
dans mes FAQ dans mes entretiens dès que
j'en ai eu l'occasion et ben non vu
qu'Antoine Goya n'écoute pas ce que je
dis vu qu'il a besoin de vous vendre une
version qui l'arrange il en arrive à me
faire dire l'exact opposé de ce que je
dis et moi mon problème avec Charles
Robin c'est qu'en fait il donne une
impression de neutralité c'est quelqu'un
lorsqu'il s'exprime lorsqu'il parle qui
veut avoir absolument l'air neutre en
fait il y a pas de lecture neutre d'un
philosophe ça c'est du pipeau
ça n'existe pas ne vous laissez pas
avoir par les impressions de neutralité
des mecs surtout par Charles Robin il
est pas du tout neutre lorsque je parle
d'un philosophe sur ma chaîne youtube je
le fais toujours à partir de mon point
de vue la prétention à l'objectivité la
prétention à la neutralité scientifique
lorsqu'on parle de philosophie me paraît
totalement absurde et insensé ça là
strictement aucun sens c'est quelqu'un
lorsqu'il s'exprime lorsqu'il parle qui
veut avoir absolument l'air neutre on ne
peut pas atteindre la neutralité on ne
peut pas atteindre l'objectivité et moi
j'ai pas la prétention à être objectif
ou neutre j'ai appris attention à être
honnête à essayer d'être honnête lui il
fait semblant d'être neutre moi j'ai
jamais fait semblant d'être neutres et
c'est ce que j'ai constaté pendant
toutes mes études et pendant tout mon
travail sur des philosophes c'est que tu
intègres et que tu inquiètes dans les
auteurs ta propre sensibilité je suis
d'une totale et parfaite neutralité
était d'accord avec ça mentir c'est pas
bien on est d'accord mentir c'est pas
bien
je parle de la zététique je dis qu'il
faut faire la distinction entre la
zététique et les youtubeurs qui font de
la zététique autrement dit qu'il faut
faire la différence entre une méthode et
son application ce qui me semble être
quelque chose de plutôt basique je passe
mon temps à expliquer que l'esprit
critique et quelque chose de fondamental
à expliquer qu'il ne faut pas me suivre
aveuglément qu'il faut soumettre tout ce
que je dis à l'examen critique et ben
dans la bouche d'Antoine Goya ça devient
Charles Robin essaye de vous éloigner de
l'esprit critique il y a la zététique et
il y a les youtubeurs qui font les
zététiques c'est deux choses distinctes
parce que oui Charles Robin a un combat
dans sa vie c'est la zététique le mec
combat la zététique une démarche très
noble très louable que j'encourage
d'ailleurs dans mes vidéos dans ce
scepticisme parce que moi quelqu'un qui
critique la zététique qui critique
l'esprit critique il critique le fait de
ok je crois ça est-ce que c'est vrai oui
ou non je me demande toujours mais
quelle merde il essaie de me vendre ce
type là la merde il essaye de me vendre
pour vouloir endormir mon esprit
critique je considère l'esprit critique
comme une arme une arme d'autodéfense et
je le prendrai jusqu'à mon dernier
souffle quel est son intérêt quel est le
risque pour lui à m'empêcher d'aller
consulter du contenu un peu qui va
essayer de faire travailler mon esprit
critique quel est son risque à lui je ne
veux absolument pas que vous puissiez
reconnaître en moi quelqu'un que vous
allez suivre de manière aveugle
c'est-à-dire sans faire fonctionner
votre esprit critique moi je vois ça je
me dis le mec cherche à me vendre de la
merde et cherche à me mettre de la merde
dans la tête pour mieux me soutirer mon
fric c'est à dire que arrivé et vous
balancer ce que je pense vous dire ce
que je crois bien ce que je crois mal ce
que je crois vrai ce que je crois faut
ça n'a aucun sens si vous n'avez pas les
outils pour évaluer pour examiner pour
soumettre au jugement critique tout ce
que je pourrais vous dire je me demande
toujours mais quelle merde il essaie de
me vendre ce type là quelle est la merde
il essaye de me vendre pour essayer de
vouloir endormir mon esprit critique et
pour vouloir m'éloigner voilà c'est
parce qu'en fait c'est un enfermement de
t'éloigner en fait un peu de dire non
zététique non non c'est pas très bien
par quelques types qui ont perdu toutes
notion de réflexion et qui boivent les
paroles comme ça d'un vidéaste parce
qu'il le trouve sympathique parce qu'il
l'aime bien parce que c'est leur idole
etc mais en fait tu pouvais convaincre
personne je parle du complotisme je dis
que le complotisme c'est d'abord le
résultat d'une perte de confiance dans
les autorités d'une paire de confiance
dans les institutions que si on veut
combattre le complotisme il faut d'abord
tenir compte de ce facteur de la perte
de confiance que c'est bien beau de se
moquer des complotistes mais que c'est
pas comme ça qu'on recrée de la
confiance et ben dans la bouche
d'Antoine Goya ça devient Charles Robin
prend le parti des complotistes et il
fait du relativisme Charles Robin il
prend le parti de ce qu'on appellerait
entre guillemets des complotistes
d'accord il prend les parties des
complotistes et il veut un peu les
caresser dans le sens du poil sans doute
parce que c'est une partie de son public
aussi les complotistes et le complotisme
selon moi il est d'abord le produit de
la perte totale de confiance du peuple
dans les gouvernants si
ton élève enfin ton enfant va à l'école
tous les jours mais que tu lui dis que
tout ce qu'on va lui raconter à l'école
c'est des conneries
le prof il aura beau être aussi bon
compétent qui voudra on leur a dit tout
ça c'est des conneries donc c'est la
confiance qui détermine le taux de
pénétration de l'éducation partant de là
si on travaille pas sur la confiance on
travaille sur rien c'est à dire qu'on ne
devient pas complotiste du jour au
lendemain sans savoir pourquoi parce que
l'envie nous en prend tu ne peux pas
d'accord tu ne peux pas faire du
relativisme comme ça à faire semblant
que tout est croyances se valent etc il
y a des croyances ils sont ridicules ce
qu'évidemment qu'il y aura toujours des
complotistes caricaturaux qui vont
défendre des tests complètement farfelus
complètement grotesque et qu'il est bien
pratique d'ailleurs de pouvoir les
désigner du doigt pour dire que voilà ce
qu'est le complotisme je suis pour la
finesse du langage je suis pour la
nuance et pour la précision et donc je
refuse de me plier à des catégories qui
pour moi sont des catégories
complètement manipulatoires essaye de
saisir intellectuellement le propos de
la personne avant d'ouvrir ta gueule ce
serait pas mal ce serait pas mal cette
évitera de te faire ridiculiser en fait
je dis que les complotistes n'ont pas
confiance dans la science j'explique que
quand je dis la science je parle de la
parole scientifique officielle je parle
du consensus scientifique actuel mais ça
Antoine Goya le couple et il nous fait
tout un anus pour nous expliquer que
tout le monde croit dans la science
alors je sais que c'est quelque chose
qui est réfuté par la science comment on
l'appelle c'est à dire le consensus
scientifique actuel c'est là qui se fout
totalement de votre gueule il y a
personne qui ne croit pas dans la
science d'accord il y a personne qui
croit pas dans la science même le truc
le plus ésotérique le plus débile
possible genre Thierry casasnova si
votre soigner avec des jus ton cancer
qui dit ton bras peut repousser et tout
lorsqu'il en a l'occasion il va lui-même
malgré tout sortir une étude
scientifique la science comment on
l'appelle c'est à dire le consensus
scientifique actuel c'est à dire qu'en
fait
tout le monde croit dans la science tout
le monde fait confiance dans la science
les gens même les pires charlatans
utilisent des preuves scientifiques vont
utiliser des études scientifiques vont
utiliser des arguments scientifiques
donc tout le monde croit dans la science
la science intellectuellement je pense
cette personne est extrêmement limitée
et elle me déçoit bon et puis j'ai gardé
le meilleur pour la fin parce que au
début de ma réponse j'ai dit qu'Antoine
Goya avait esquivé le sujet de Tolstoï
en fait c'est pire que ça Antoine a
essayé de répondre sur Tolstoï il a
répondu que ce qui l'intéressait chez
Tolstoï c'était sa réflexion moi ce que
j'ai trouvé intéressant dans le bouquin
Tolstoï c'était sa réflexion sa
réflexion qui poussait à donner une
définition de l'art sans prendre en
compte le critère subjectif qui est le
beau et comme preuve de sa bonne
compréhension de Tolstoï il a affiché
dans sa vidéo un extrait de la préface
qui serait la preuve que le préfacier
est d'accord avec Antoine et c'est
également ce que dit le préfacé du
bouquin voilà peut-être regarde moi j'ai
une mission numérique tout pourri j'ai
pas cette préface mais toi tu l'as voilà
et quand on regarde le résumé du livre
sur Internet on voit qu'est-ce qu'on
peut voir on peut dire cette phrase
importante de la préface voilà donc toi
bon peut-être ce livre ne tue pas
vraiment lu mais en tout cas le prix
facile lui la lui il l'a compris ah il a
compris la même chose que moi et c'est
là où on va s'amuser rappelez-vous ce
que je reprochais ah Antoine Goya dans
ma précédente FAQ je l'ai reproché de
tronquer les propos de Tolstoï pour les
faire correspondre à ce qu'il cherchait
à démontrer et ben devinez ce qu'a fait
Antoine avec cet extrait de la préface
il a fait la même chose Antoine Goya a
tronqué l'extrait de la préface qu'il
vous a présenté on est dans un niveau de
culot difficile à imaginer alors voilà
la citation quand toi n'a affiché dans
sa vidéo Tolstoï a cherché à comprendre
le sens de l'art et non à en étudier
l'effet il a montré par sa réflexion que
l'on devait pouvoir poncer l'art en
dehors du beau compris comme sentiment
subjectif
sauf que il manque un morceau
et comme par hasard le morceau qui
manque bah il modifie complètement le
sens de ces deux phrases voici le
passage dans son intégralité
c'est-à-dire avec les deux phrases
manquantes
Tolstoï a donc cherché à comprendre le
sens de l'art et non en étudier l'effet
sa vision de l'art c'est cristallisée au
moment donné de sa vie où il lui
importait de conforter son assétisme son
refus du corps et de la sensualité
propre à la religion cette dernière
étape dans la recherche de soi du Grand
Créateur correspond plus qu'on ne croit
à une volonté de retrouver le grand
créateur dans ses dessins intimes si ce
n'est plus ainsi qu'on envisage l'art
aujourd'hui et ensuite on a la fin de la
citation autrement dit Antoine Goya a
coupé l'extrait de la citation dans
lequel le préfacier explique que le sens
de l'art pour Tolstoï c'est la religion
vous voyez la malice c'est à dire que si
on lit la citation tronquée on croit que
pour Tolstoï le sens de l'art c'est le
fait qu'il soit indépendant de la beauté
et elle est là la manipulation c'est à
dire que nous expliquer que Tolstoï
rejette le critère de la beauté pour
pouvoir ensuite défendre l'art
contemporain c'est ne pas comprendre
pourquoi Tolstoï a rejeté le critère de
la beauté c'est utiliser un auteur pour
lui faire dire le contraire de ce qu'il
dit et c'est faire semblant de ne pas
comprendre en quoi c'est malhonnête quel
sens ça de prendre des bouts de
raisonnement d'un auteur pour finalement
lui faire dire le contraire de ce qu'il
dit les auteurs c'est pas un supermarché
c'est comme si prenait les pièces d'un
puzzle déjà formé pour les mettre dans
d'autres puzzles qui n'ont rien à voir
et ne va surtout pas te réfugier
derrière l'argument de l'éclectisme
c'est-à-dire que oui on peut citer un
auteur sans être d'accord avec tout ce
qui dit évidemment qu'on peut citer un
qu'il dit mais la question elle est pas
là la question c'est de savoir est-ce
que oui ou non tu trahis la pensée d'un
auteur quand tu le sites comme ça
imaginons Antoine par exemple que demain
tu accèdes au pouvoir
et que dans ta folie totalitaire tu
décides de supprimer l'intégralité des
partis politiques tu décides de
supprimer tous les partis politiques
parce que tu ne veux pas te concurrence
donc tu décides de supprimer tous les
partis politiques et pour justifier ça
tu vas t'en référer à Simone Veil la
philosophe qui était pour la suppression
des partis politiques et tu sais
pourquoi elle était pour la suppression
des partis politiques parce qu'elle
estimait que les partis politiques
étaient des machines à fabriquer de la
passion collective et qu'elles
éloignaient le peuple du bien commun tu
imagines un tyran qui si très Simone
veille pour pouvoir justifier de
supprimer les partis politiques
et ben c'est exactement la même chose
que tu as fait avec Tolstoï on peut
avoir des influences multiples on peut
être séduit et intéressé par tel aspect
de la pensée d'un auteur et l'être moins
par tel autre aspect mais ça nous
autorise pas à faire du dépeçage
intellectuel ça nous autorise pas à
prendre un petit bout de raisonnement et
à leur accorder à un autre bout de
raisonnement une pensée c'est organique
toi ce que tu fais c'est du bricolage et
le pire dans tout ça c'est que tu
utilises ce bricolage pour te donner des
airs de supériorité intellectuelle donc
ne cache pas derrière l'argument de
j'utilise ce qui m'intéresse parce
qu'après tout ce qui compte c'est la
réflexion la réflexion Tolstoï tu t'en
moques complètement parce que tu n'as
pas compris que le fondement de sa
réflexion c'était comment justifier le
critère religieux en art en fait le
problème d'Antoine Goya c'est pas qu'il
est bête
c'est qu'il croit que les gens sont
bêtes et du coup ça le rend embête ou
alors j'ai ma théorie ma théorie c'est
que peut-être qu'Antoine Goya et
finalement beaucoup plus intelligent
qu'on ne le soupçonne et que à travers
sa mauvaise foi et ça malhonnête et il
cherche à nous faire comprendre quelque
chose Antoine Goya c'est quelqu'un qui
s'est donné pour mission de déboulonner
toutes les idoles sur Youtube et
maintenant qu'il est lui-même devenu un
youtubeur maintenant qu'il a des fans
qu'il a une communauté qui les
considérait comme un gourou par un grand
nombre de ses spectateurs et bien leur
est venu pour lui de s'attaquer à son
propre déboulonnage et donc c'est pour
ça qu'il est devenu tout le contraire de
ce qu'il a toujours prôné pour voir
jusqu'à quel point ces fans seraient
prêts à le suivre dans son naufrage ma
théorie c'est Antoine Goya a mis en
scène sa propre mauvaise foi et sa
propre malhonnêteté
pour prouver à tout le monde qu'il ne
fallait jamais faire confiance à un
youtubeur
y compris à lui
[Musique]
tu es grillé là tu es finie après cette
vidéo là je suis désolé tu es fini tu es
plus rien